hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a mystery psychological thriller
film called before i go to sleep
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the film opens with an extreme close-up
on the bloodshot eye of christine lucas
a 40 year old woman who wakes up in a
bedroom she does not recognize
she has no idea where she is and does
not recognize anything around her
she realizes with shock that there is a
middle-aged man sleeping in the bed next
to her
she goes to the bathroom and finds
pictures taped to the wall of herself as
a much older woman
she also sees a picture of the man in
the bed next to her labeled
ben your husband none of it rings a bell
confronting the man in the bedroom he
tells her that he is her husband
ben they have been married for decades
he tells her she was involved in a
terrible car accident 10 years earlier
that left her with brain damage every
evening when she goes to sleep
she forgets everything waking up with a
blank slate the next morning
with no memory of her life from her
early 20s onwards
ben has to go through the same routine
every morning he shows christine
photographs
while telling her the story of their
romance and marriage
ben then gets ready for work and leaves
to go teach at a nearby school
while christine looks around the house a
neurologist named dr nash calls the
house
he informs her that she has been in
treatment with him for the past few
years
he tells her to locate a video camera
which is hidden inside her closet
dr nash tells christine not to inform
benefit camera
he tells her to watch the videos and to
call him back christine watches a video
diary of herself
which she is unfamiliar with she has
recorded a video diary over the last two
weeks
prompting an extended flashback to
illustrate what she's learned so far
she then meets dr nash who explains that
she has been seeing him for some time
without her husband's knowledge
he tries to help her deal with her
condition dr nash further reveals that
her memory loss occurred 10 years ago
after she was attacked and left for dead
near an airport hotel
however she is very confused her husband
then said that she had a car accident
she wonders why ben lied to her about
the cause of her amnesia
dr nash suggests perhaps it's just
easier
dr nash then takes her back to where she
was found after the attack
hoping it would trigger her memory she
was found by the airport
the man who found her explains that it
was a long time ago
she was found with blood all over her
body she was naked
apart from a plastic sheet from a nearby
hotel she questions
why would she be staying in a hotel
which dr nash suggests she was having an
affair
the medical examination indicated she
had sexual intercourse just before the
attack
later that evening she's back home and
begins to record her new discovery
at night when she sleeps flash cut
memories emerge
the moment she got attacked by someone
in a hotel
the next day dr nash shows her some
pictures some were taken random
others from her file one particular
picture causes distinct neural
excitation
the picture of a red-haired woman named
claire
at home when she asks ben about this ben
tells her that claire was her best
friend who couldn't handle christine's
condition after the accident
she has moved abroad and ended contact
with christine
ben then shows her pictures with claire
saying he kept this hidden from her to
protect her
the next day christine gets flashes of
memory and recalls that she had a son
she angrily confronts ben over hiding
their child however to her surprise
he says their son named adam died of
meningitis when he was eight
he has been keeping all these secrets
away from her to protect her from
reliving the pain of that experience
afterward while crying she continues to
record this painful discoveries
while sleeping christine continues to
struggle with her memories of baby adam
which culminate in a wickedly weird
dream a dream where adam leaves her a
drawing of a man with a scar on his face
the picture is labeled mike the next
morning
she tells dr nash that she thinks mike
was the name of the man she had an
affair with
he was her attacker nash hugs her to
comfort her
he almost kisses her however his jacket
opens to reveal his hospital id and his
full name
mike nash she sees a vision where nash
attacks her in a hotel
christine immediately pulls back and
runs from him but he catches her and
administers a sedative
leaving her at home later that day her
phone rings
it's dr nash he tells her that he
administered a mild sedative to calm her
down
he explains to her that she experienced
what they call confabulation
her imagination filling in the gaps in
her memory turning him into the man who
did this to her
the next day christine again meets dr
nash
he doesn't feel he can treat her anymore
because he has feelings for her and it's
completely unprofessional
before they part dr nash tells her a
shocking revelation
in 2007 ben had placed her in an
assisted care facility
and later in 2009 he divorced her
leaving her in the care facility
furthermore her best friend claire had
been trying to contact her at the care
facility
nash then gives claire's phone number to
her after hearing that revelation
christine angrily confronts her husband
asking the reason he divorced her four
years ago
she demands to know the truth there he
reveals that when they lost their son
he got depressed so he divorced her
leaving her in the care facility
however he soon changed his mind and
came back to her
he promises that he will never leave her
again knowing this truth
christine understands his situation and
she hugs him
later that day christine contacted her
best friend claire
as she hears claire's voice she begins
to get glimpses of her past memories
with claire
they agree to meet at a local park in
their meeting claire reveals why their
relationship drifted apart
christine's husband ben and claire had a
one-time sexual encounter
due to their shared grief at christine's
memory loss feeling obliged to keep ben
and christine's marriage
intact claire ended contact with her and
stay away from their lives
after apologizing claire gives christine
a letter written to her by ben
ben sent this to her shortly before they
got separated
he asked claire to give it to christine
should she ever be well enough to read
it
in the letter ben tells christine that
he loves her but he had to place her in
the care facility due to her condition
she looked happy there he decided to
leave her for their son adam's sake
adam was unable to understand her memory
loss and begun to be afraid of her
ben believed for adam's sake that they
needed to leave her and he begs her to
understand
after reading this letter christine
understands how difficult it was for ben
to deal with christine's amnesia
out of gratitude for his love and care
christine records a video
saying that ben is her lover and
protector and she wants to make a life
with him
at night she decides to let ben see the
video she has made on the digital camera
she also tells him that she has been
seeing dr nash for quite some time
she admits she didn't trust ben before
but she completely trusts him now
however ben angrily accuses christine of
having an affair with nash
he strikes her and storms out on the
telephone christine talks to claire
about what just happened
claire is confused because she knows ben
and he is a very good gentleman
he will never strike her like that so
claire decides to give ben a call
a few moments later claire rings
christine back
she tells christine that ben claims not
to have seen christine for four years
claire asks christine to describe the
ben she is living with whether he has a
scar across the right side of his face
she checks ben's picture no scar that
moment
they realize the man she is living with
is not bad
the wedding photo is fake christine
immediately attempts to escape the house
but then renders her unconscious the
next morning
christine again awakens with no memories
she finds the camera and sees her entry
saying she loves ben
and wants to make a life with him ben
calls christine and tells her to pack
that they are going on a trip that night
that night ben
takes her to a hotel close to where she
had been found in the hotel room
she gets glimpses of what happened 10
years ago he reveals that he is mike
the man she had an affair with christine
then remembers
that mike had wanted christine to reveal
their affair to ben but christine
refused
their argument culminated in mike
viciously attacking christine
resulting in her amnesia he also
inadvertently reveals
that christine's son adam is still alive
declaring his love for christine
mike deletes the videos on her camera
and states that he is no longer
interested in playing the part of ben
he tells christine that they shall live
together or no one shall live
another struggle ensues but this time
christine knocks mike out and gets away
she sets off a hotel fire alarm while
running from the hotel
and is seen telling her story on the
camera while waiting in an ambulance
christine wakes up in a hospital bed and
is visited by nash
this time as a friend and not as her
therapist he assures her the man
responsible for her condition mike
has been arrested he tells christine
that she has visitors and that he hopes
the visit will provide the breakthrough
they have been hoping for
the real ben comes to visit christine
and he's brought someone else
adam their son who never died of
meningitis
as she sees adam entering her room her
memories return
with tears full of joy the two of them
hug each other and the movie ends
now for the explanation i will explain
the sequence of events that happened
prior to the events in the movie in 1999
christine and ben got married but not
this ben
the real ben in august 1999
their son adam was born after four years
in 2003 christine had an affair with
mike
mike wanted christine to reveal their
affair to ben but christine refused and
their argument culminated in mike
viciously attacking christine
resulting in her amnesia due to her
condition ben
placed her in an adult community care
center then
and her son adam visited her daily but
they had to suffer as they needed to
remind her of her identity daily
during this time her best friend claire
helped the family
and got closer to ben one day van and
claire had a one-time sexual encounter
due to their shared grief at christine's
memory loss feeling guilty
claire decided to stay away from their
lives after a few years
christine's condition hadn't got any
better ben couldn't go on anymore
their son adam grew desperately unhappy
therefore in 2009 van and adam left
christine
for adam's sake they left her in the
care facility not visiting her anymore
mike used this opportunity to disguise
himself as her husband
mike forged ben's signature and took her
home with him for four years
she was tricked into thinking that he
was her husband until one day
she met dr nash who gave her a camera to
record her thoughts and progress each
day
what happens next are the events that
you saw in the film and that's my
explanation for the movie
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching